Death is something that all of us must deal
with at some point in our lives - whether
it be a family member, a pet, or even your
own eventual end. In fact, about 100 people
die every minute in the world. But what actually
happens when you die?
In the first few seconds after death, the
last bit of oxygen in your body is depleted
and brain activity surges. As the neurons
begin to stop functioning, your brain stops
secreting hormones which regulate body function.
And while some bodily functions may persist
for a few minutes, as the remaining stores
of ATP are used - which is your body’s main
energy source - the muscles relax, including
sphincters, which means defecation and urination
may occur.
Around 15-25 minutes after death, the lack
of blood flow through the capillaries leads
to the paleness of death seen in light skinned
people. Because your heart is no longer running,
there is no active propulsion of blood through
the body so gravity begins to cause pooling
of blood in the lowest parts of the body.
After a few hours of blood pooling a reddish
purple discolouration of the skin occurs,
and reaches its maximum discolouration by
12 hours. This is one of the ways in which
coroners and forensic investigators determine
the approximate time and position of a body
at death.
Within 3-6 hours, the infamous rigor mortis
sets in; not only has your body lost its energy
source, but deterioration of cellular organelles
leaks calcium into muscles cells, and this
binds to proteins which are responsible for
muscle contraction. This causes uncontrolled
tensing or stiffness of muscles, making the
body ‘stuck’ in a position, lasting anywhere
from 24-48 hours.
Up to this point, unless you’ve been chemically
embalmed or preserved in some manner, your
body has been slowly decomposing as well,
undergoing cell death. Without proper blood
flow, these dead cells accumulate and along
with CO2 gas, cause the ph of tissues to rise.
This weakens the cell membrane, eventually
causing them to burst and release their cytosol,
which contains functioning proteins and enzymes
that further breakdown surrounding tissue.
There are also around 100 trillion microorganisms
that help to break down your body. The anaerobic
bacteria in the gastrointestinal tract begin
to eat through abdominal organs. This process
is known as putrefaction and it’s where
things get stinky. Breakdown of amino acids
by the bacteria produces extremely foul gases,
which attracts certain insects like mites,
carrion beetles and blowflies which lay eggs
in the rotting tissue. The eggs hatch within
a day, and the larvae or maggots eat the tissue
to survive until they mature.
After weeks, these maggots may consume 60%
of the body’s tissue, creating holes that
allow decomposition fluids and gasses to escape.
Between 20-50 days, butyric fermentation begins,
attracting beetle larvae, protozoa and fungi.
This process, known as dry decay, can take
up to a year, but occurs faster in hotter
temperatures.
Over years, plants and animals eat away at
the remaining bits of the body, including
skeletal remains. Eventually, if left completely
to the elements, every bit of the body will
be broken down and its constituent molecules
will be recycled.
If you’d like to learn more about the psychological
side of death, check out our AsapTHOUGHT video
on the Top 5 Regrets People Have Before Dying.
It’s a fascinating look at the things people
think about in their last moments. Link in
the description!
And subscribe!